russia has a hold over the west because
of the energy it supplies to it
forty percent of europe's gas for
example comes from russia
but moscow's reliance on fossil fuels
for income also makes it vulnerable
especially to a coordinated
international boycott the united states
is targeting the main artery of russia's
economy
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy that means russian
oil will no longer be acceptable at u.s
ports and the american people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
the uk will do the same with oil by the
end of the year we won't see the
elimination
of russian oil imports during the course
of the year this phased approach strikes
a good balance between eliminating uh
reliance on russian oil
but also allowing people time
and people in the market to adapt to the
new situation
even the european union despite its
reliance on russian energy is taking
steps to pull away
we can do it
and we can do it fast
all we need is the courage and grit
to get us there if ever there was a time
to do it it's now
russia is biting back
it has already threatened to stop gas
supplies to the west by the nordstream
one pipeline and warns of the further
consequences of a boycott it will be
much more expensive for european
consumers
in this scenario they will be the main
victims
european politicians should then
honestly warn their citizens consumers
what awaits them
and that the prices at gas stations for
electricity and heating will skyrocket
all the uncertainty and disruption is
already impacting consumers around the
world and at home here in the uk fuel
prices have soared to record highs the
average cost of diesel close to hitting
165 pence per liter and unleaded petrol
160.
although the uk is much less dependent
on russian energy than its european
counterparts the government must now
take steps to insulate this country from
foreign powers who weaponize energy
supply
in the coming days boris johnson will
set out his energy supply strategy and
that is likely to include new investment
in renewables and nuclear power
but he's also under pressure partly from
within his own party to start digging
for more oil and gas in the uk's north
sea and that may well happen
all other agendas for the moment
sidelined as the international community
scrambles to punish russian aggression
and stop a growing global energy crisis
hannah thomas peter sky news